foreign
I've been gambling on Sports since I was
12.
it has ruined every aspect of my life
shattered everything and I just can't
kick it man I'm just feeling more and
more defeated I can hear it in you
[Music]
what up what up this is John with the Dr
John deloney's show
the greatest marriage and mental health
and relationship podcast ever created
um Hey listen
one of the greatest ways you can support
the show with no money no you don't have
to send anything just to hit the
Subscribe button if you'll just
subscribe or if you will go to wherever
you're listening to this on podcast and
just give a five star review I'm all
about lying I'm all about you thinking
this is actually a three-star show and
that's actually pretty generous too
but you're going ahead and hitting the
five I won't tell I think you have a
cosmic pass to uh give a soldier listen
Kelly needs this that's just that's what
this comes down to Kelly needs this
um but hey it is a no-cost
um easy way for you to support the show
and I'm super grateful for it and what
it does is it kicks it up into the
algorithms and it makes it available to
more people who are searching for things
that the show can help them with and so
it's less about vanity
um I've got a 12 year old and a
six-year-old daughter and my vanity is
out the window because she Hey listen to
this Kelly yesterday I was uh my
daughter and I were playing uh air
hockey and she beat me
and we were yelling and trash talking
and going back and forth and then on the
way up the stairs from the basement she
looked at me and goes hey Dad and I said
yeah and she goes what's wrong with you
so listen I don't this isn't for my
vainglory this actually helps other
people get the help that they need when
they go searching for these topics so
leave your five star reviews hit
subscribe and I would be really really
grateful and by the way I'm a part of a
network that's got all kind of different
shows on it um whether it's shows about
career or how to deal with your money
all kind of things so check out the
Ramsay Network for other shows all right
let's go out to uh Baltimore and talk to
Kevin what's up Kevin
hey Dr John how are you I'm all right
brother how are you
um pretty horrible but um I feel very
fortunate that um I'm able to speak to
you today so well man let's let's get
into it what's up
so I'm 23 years old and um I've been
gambling on Sports since I was 12.
um
it has ruined every aspect of my life
shattered everything
um and you know I'm I've listened to a
lot of your stuff and you know I've I've
done a lot of things to try and put
myself in a position to get better
um I've gone to GA I'm still going to GA
um I've seen a therapist that
specializes in this kind of thing
um
and I just can't kick it man and I'm
feeling I'm just feeling more and more
defeated by by the second by the minute
by the day so
um just hoping that maybe you can give
me any wisdom or or just advice to maybe
help me out
yeah man I can hear it in you
you're all those people say that you
sound exhausted
yeah that's yeah
are you you sound way past tired you
sound exhausted
yeah I also haven't slept in
um
since Sunday really maybe a few hours so
it keeps me up all day and just makes me
hate myself more every day so I mean
just in a bad spot there you go
um are you coming off anything
um no what do you mean in terms of like
drugs or alcohol yeah do you use
no I I don't drink or do any drugs at
all so gambling has just always been
been the thing what what how did this
become part of your life
yeah so this is the the real sad part is
just that like
um hey hold on hold on I want to start
I'm gonna stop you there
like
you and I are friends now and I'm gonna
at least while you're on the phone with
me you're not gonna talk about Kevin
like that anymore
okay that you're sad that you're a loser
and that everything sucks you're not
gonna talk like that anymore
okay okay that's a choice to put on a
like a like a black trench coat of
weight right that you don't need to
carry is that cool yeah yeah so tell
like we'll get into all the nitty-gritty
all the guts and blood and all that
stuff yeah but at least when you're on
the phone with me you're not gonna talk
to yourself and talk about yourself that
way is that cool all right I appreciate
you checking me on that yeah so um 12 12
years old what was going on in your
world
so so I was never really like the brains
of the family and sports were always my
thing I was a great athlete you know I
played all all the sports and
um so I guess when I was I think a
freshman freshman High School my friend
had an older brother that was like a
bookie that would take bets and um
that's like really how I you know kind
of got started I mean I was basically
gambling with lunch money then at that
point but wow but yeah I mean you know
ever since then it's just it's just
gotten worse and you know I've gone I've
gone days I've maybe gone a week or two
but you know for the past literal decade
I I have not been able to
successfully stop for any long period of
time and I'll also say that you know for
the past decade I haven't been making a
concentrate effort you know to fully
stop but right at least for the at least
for the past year or two man I've I've
been grinding so hard and I know it's
people just say just stop like what's so
hard no that seems that simple but I'm
not going to tell you that that's
Madness yeah
um but seriously just stop Kevin just
stop I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
yeah um yeah
oh there's so much here okay there's a
couple things I'm gonna walk through
with you would you be willing to talk to
a buddy of mine
I would talk to anyone that would love
that would like to talk to me absolutely
would you do it this morning this isn't
like a gotcha move but I'm gonna talk to
you through a couple things
um but there's somebody that I met via
um Instagram of all places and who's
walked a journey and he's about a year
and a half ahead of you on this
um yeah if I if I invited him into this
conversation would that be cool
yeah absolutely okay it'll be a little
clunky because we none of this is
planned or prepped or anything but um
here's what I want to I want to start
you with what have you tried to stop how
have you tried to stop
yeah so
um I've my parents are extremely
supportive
um and that that makes me kind of feel
even worse just because I continue to
let them down but um they can see you
know they can see all my money um they
can see what comes in and what goes out
um like I said I've been to GA
um I've self-excluded myself from
castinos but that doesn't really stop
you from going in there it's just kind
of like a a thing that you can do that
is supposed to help but unless the
security person recognizes you in there
and sees that you're not you're not you
know that you're you're you've
self-banned they're not going to do
anything so yeah
um and you know the the the part that
sucks is just that like with sports
Femme specifically like there are so
many offshore books the illegal like if
you want to get money on something you
can get money on it you know that's just
like the reality of it yes and you know
I've tried the self-excluding I've tried
Banning myself but ultimately I've kind
of just realized like
I I I have to be like I have to get to a
point where it just doesn't even entice
me you know because it's always going to
be there I can't just exclude exclude
exclude you know it doesn't seem like
that's a viable option or it's like
somebody who struggles with disordered
eating if you're a Coke addict you can
just quit doing I mean you can stop
surrounding yourself with cocaine if you
struggle with disordered eating you've
got to make peace with food because you
can't just avoid it right exactly and
you you've nailed it you are it living
in this weird little sliver of history
when you have virtually unlimited access
to credit to money and virtually
unlimited access to gambling and now
that with the last four years we just
stuck in your cell phone right we put in
your pocket yeah you don't have to you
don't have to go anywhere right exactly
um yeah so at some point here's what I'm
hearing
I'm hearing a guy at War
and I've never met anybody ever
Who quote unquote defeated
their addiction
yeah I've never heard that I've never
heard a guy or or a woman who defeats
alcoholism
I've heard somebody take a knee and
submit
yeah and you get the difference there
it's a totally different way of doing
life yeah and I was going to say too one
of the things that like actually scares
me the most is that there's a guy in um
in the ga that I go to who's been clean
since 89 and he says every single time
that he's just a day away like anyone
else from stepping into a casino and
gambling and I just think I know he's
saying that to make us feel like you
know like we can get through it but to
me it feels like if I have to live with
this like for the rest of my life like
how I I don't know if I can do that like
like he's one day away like am I always
gonna be one day am I always gonna feel
this like because I I can't live like
this man I can't listen you're not gonna
feel what you've got right now no
the dial the dial turns back
right
yeah um
like
dude I want to hug you so bad I should
give you a hug man well now I just think
too like you know there's just so much
stuff that goes into this and I just
think like like I just feel like I've
been robbed of every Joy like my
dopamine is just so
cracked out from all of this gambling
that like if I can even get to a point
where I can stop like am I ever even
gonna find Joy like you know it just
feels like an uphill battle to even stop
and then I feel like okay once I get to
the top like am I even gonna be happy
like is anything even gonna change or am
I just going to be robbed of the one
thing that at least brought me you know
dope you know you know what I mean yeah
totally yeah yeah I mean hold on hang on
the line here I'm gonna bring
um I'm gonna bring Craig up hang on one
second okay
okay
Craig are you there how's it going Dr
John I'm good my brother hey
um this is so just so everybody knows
this morning early this morning I I was
checking the just my calendar today and
I looked at the show notes and I saw
this was this call was coming Jenna had
sent these in
and so Greg it's the first time you and
I've ever spoken person but we met via
Instagram and you reached out and over
the last year and a half you have just
I mean you've changed every aspect of
your life in a in a profound way man so
it's a it's such a gift and an honor to
hear from you over the last year and a
half as you've changed everything and um
I appreciate you I just reached out this
morning it's like hey this is a
curveball would you mind jumping on a
call with me this morning so I man I
appreciate you going for it dude
this is uh what I've learned is a part
of uh giving back so um I was happy to
do that and um I'm grateful that was the
same I was the same person
633 days ago wow so you you've heard
this you've been on the on the line
since Kevin started talking tell me how
familiar this sounds to you
um it sounds exactly like me at 23 only
I'm 43 now okay and I wish I had the
guts and courage uh for what he's doing
now
um but I will say this 23 year old Craig
would have not been ready to stop
um I only stopped
when I was absolutely ready and uh for
me it was just the right time the right
moment the right place I was uh
desperate just like him I think it was
December 28th or 29th I was at my Wit's
End and I was
emailing you or messaging you on
Instagram and I just was pouring my guts
out and I never thought that anybody
would even read it or or look at it and
a couple days later you got back to me
and you said one thing that stuck with
me
and that made me realize
that I needed help and it was that you
cannot do this alone
and my whole life since I'm 10 years old
I was trying to do it alone and that's
when I finally reached out for help
and then here you are man you just sent
me some pictures of your wedding a few
few weeks ago man so walk walk us
through you've you've I mean you've paid
off like a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in debt you're cleaning your
whole life is changing
that is correct um for me the biggest
thing
uh was connection
um
my uh gambling brought me to isolation
and just wanting to be alone and uh
forgetting what it was like to be a
human and when I listened to you and I
said when you said that you couldn't do
this alone
I started research and help I found an
online support group and through that
online support group I actually found
two gentlemen in South Florida that are
now my mentors that I speak to every
single day and I even visit them and One
Mentor had 50 has 52 years in the
program he's number 14 in the world of
being a clean from gambling his name is
his nickname is Spa bracelets and the
other guy's name is sake and they've
been with me every single day since day
three
and for me
it was about letting it out having
someone to talk to
um not being ashamed anymore getting it
off my chest
um two guys that have been there before
and uh understood it because only
another compulsive Gambler is going to
understand another compulsive Gambler so
Hey Kevin you're there
yeah so here's what I'm hearing the
difference between what you're saying
and a guy that's a year and a half ahead
of you or two years ahead of you okay
is you're going to the meetings
you are interacting with your family you
are trying to fight this thing
but you're doing it completely and
totally by yourself
do you get the difference
I think so yeah or let me put it this
way you can go to the you can go to
meetings
and be surrounded by people
who say we love you Kevin welcome Kevin
and you can feel completely and totally
alone
oh yeah that's that's to a t yeah
and there's something
um different about going to a meeting
and then doing what Craig did sitting
across from somebody and saying I'm in a
mess help
which is and that's what you're doing
today actually you're reaching out and I
would say you've gone to a therapist
y'all are trying to fix things you're
trying to stop gambling
yeah that's different than
help
and if I could um I'm sorry I don't know
yeah
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna step
out and I want Craig you talked to Kevin
and Kevin you talked back to Craig here
for a minute
hey Kev there's a place online it's
called
gamblers and recovery.com
um it's 24-hour meetings from around the
world you can find a meeting every hour
on zoom and I was just like you I
actually during the pandemic I I had to
do I probably did three four five
meetings a day in the first 90 days just
to try to stay away from a bet and
having that kind of access
to people with that kind of knowledge
and who have been around
um just helped me tremendously I'm not
going to say it's easy it is the hardest
thing I ever had to do in my life
but I saw the hardest thing I ever had
to do in my life and I heard you talk
about like your joy and your dopamine
I was you times 20. and I'm and Dr John
knows some of the numbers I was you
times 20 just 20 years later and you're
gonna be me in 20 years
if you don't figure this out now
yeah you have a chance because you're
looking for help and Craig I saw some
pictures of you with this beautiful new
wife of yours are you have you found joy
in other places
that's exactly where I was getting to
um
I was the same way even having a future
fiance and then a beautiful wife and
having a daughter who plays Sports and
who's active and engaged and a great
student none of those things at the time
were making me happy or bringing me joy
632 days later
I find joy in those things again it does
subside does it go away no
no if I was somebody like you gambling
12 14 hours a day you know insane
amounts of money had no business doing
it because of access to lots and lots of
credit same exact stuff but it does
subside but it takes time it takes a lot
of time and it takes a lot of patience
and it takes a lot of effort and a lot
of work but it's worth it
so Kevin what are you hearing what are
you feeling
I mean it's
you know I I know damn well like how
hard it is but to hear that for you that
it does get better is something that I
think is really resounding to me just
because
sometimes I even like look around the
room like in GA and stuff and it just
seems like people are just even people
that have kicked it you know it just
seems like every day is like such a
battle I guess it is always going to be
that way but here's someone you know
reclaim a lot of like joys in their life
and just I mean you seem like a happy
person like just speaking to and that
okay I go weeks on end I go weeks on end
now well it's not even thinking about
gambling when I thought about gambling
24 7. I I I was like you I started when
I was 10 years old fixing
football pools in my Catholic school
with my best friend to a lady I'm not
even I started fixing football pools at
10 years old and then my land I'm gonna
share this and I'm not embarrassed my
last bet and my money doesn't mean
anything in the program but just to give
you an idea from fixing football pools
at 10 years old so my last bet was 27
000 and I have no business gambling
twenty seven thousand dollars
and and that's that was that 32-year
experience so it was just like a drug
addict I just needed more and more and
more to get the same exact feeling that
I used to get as that kid at 10 years
old fixing football polls
yeah I mean that's where we go that's
the same thing as me when I when I was
you know I started when I was in my
teens and 10 10 20 wins would make me
happy and and now if I don't have four
figures on on a game it's like uh
sometimes I don't even bother watching
if I don't have that much on it so hey
Craig let me hop in here Craig tell me
if I'm because Craig I know you've got a
heart out because you're you're a
teacher and you're working with people
um correct let me um
I'm going to say something to Kevin and
you hop in if I'm off base here okay
sure
Kevin
what I I've never found somebody who
successfully hates themselves out of bad
behavior
I've never found somebody who's able to
shame themselves into making
um long-term life change ever
so here's a way I want you to look at
this for the next few months
um you're 23 so you don't you don't have
a kid do you
no I don't okay there is something so
insanely maddening and weirdly beautiful
about having your kid wake up in the
middle of the night and come running
into your room
and say Daddy I'm sick and then barfing
on you it's dude you gotta understand
it's the worst you're dead asleep and
now some kids barfed on you and there's
something poetic about
that kid came to the one place he or she
knew to go to and they weren't okay and
that's me
and so I want you to stop thinking of
yourself as if if my kid came running
into my room and stuck their finger down
your throat and was like Hey Dad haha
embarked all over me that's a totally
different story that's the way you're
talking about yourself and so I want you
to imagine for the next six months the
next year the next six months I think
you're sick man
and you're not a bad guy you're not some
sort of dysfunctional shameful idiotic
you're sick
and the antibiotic here is going to be
other people
and if you will reframe I suck I fail
I've been trying to this thing for 10
years I've been fighting this thing
you're taking a very athletic approach
to it I will conquer I will will myself
through this
um like very David Goggins I've never
seen that work with addiction I've only
seen it I'm sitting down I'm looking at
another human being and saying I'm not
all right
yeah doctor I was the same exact way and
you're never this isn't like a program
or something that you graduate from
um you don't get any graduation and what
I've learned is
um you're not going to beat it you're
not going to conquer it it's not going
to go away you're going to arrest it
though and you can you can arrest this
disease
sometimes one minute sometimes 10
minutes sometimes an hour
sometimes a day at a time and then with
time and patience and work
you can get to a point where you're not
thinking about it 24 7 and you're not
thinking about it for days and then
you're not thinking about it for weeks
and you and you can get better
all right Craig Craig I know you got to
run what do you say Kevin I was gonna
say I think part of the issue too is
just that like I have like an amazing
girlfriend and she knows that I'm NGA
and she knows I have a problem but I'm
always just afraid to share day to day
how terrible I'm feeling just because
you know like not that it makes me a bad
person like you said I'm sick but like
this is something that ruins a lot of
relationships you know and marriages and
I just think like damn if I'm completely
open and I'm completely honest am I
going to ruin relationships when people
realize how Kevin you know what that is
that's shame right there
yeah that's shame that's all if somebody
actually knows me will they still love
me
and that that is the gasoline in the
engine of addiction
because at the core you believe no if
they really knew me she would not love
me and I call bullcrap on that I think
it's a lie too it is why and so that
when when Craig says you got to do the
work that's the work is living a life
with no secrets yes you have to be open
and honest to be able to beat this thing
you have to yeah all right Craig I know
you got to get to class man hey uh
it's an absolute honor thank you for
being brave
I appreciate it my my mentor told me you
better get your butt on that thing and
give back
good for him good for him hey I'm
grateful for you um I'll connect you to
Via uh direct message is that cool
that's perfectly fine all right man see
you Craig
all right uh uh Kevin
you still there Kevin
yeah okay
um
thank you for doing that by the way no
you got it is there you've probably had
several conversations like that and I
know they're not panaceas and I know
they're not they can't fix everything
um
Your Voice Sounds different now than it
did at the beginning of this call
yeah I think so too
so I want to
um this is like the part of the movie
when there's the Montage and someone
like starts lifting weights and Rocky
music's playing in the background I
don't want to blow over
if you are serious about getting well
the next three months are going to be
hell
there's just no way around that and he
said it at the beginning of the call you
have to decide am I ready for that am I
ready for three months of hell
and if you are man awesome All In
and if you're not make peace with not
being ready to go through hell
but all of the trash talking that you do
to Kevin is is not it's not helping
either side of this teeter-totter right
it's not making you a better Gambler and
it's not making you a well or human
being
yeah right
I think two is just I've found that
depression just goes so hand in hand
with addiction and it just seems like
absolutely dude you know even if I like
I was telling you earlier I'm just
skeptical about hell if I can go three
months without this is my life even
gonna have meaning and everyone that
I've talked to like the like the guy you
brought on say the same thing it does
get better it's just so hard for me to
believe with the way I feel but I got it
I guess I just have to trust what
everyone's telling me
can I ask you a hard question
yeah have you been right yet
no no
so let's try let's try so let's let's
try something different
yeah our feelings have one job and
that's to get us to the next day it will
even smoke a cigarette today to deal
with today's stress knowing it's going
to kill us tomorrow
and for whatever reason
your body is associated I need this fix
right now even though I know it's
killing me tomorrow
it'll get me through right now
and the goal is to create a little bit
bigger Gap and he said it he said it
beautifully sometimes that gaps one
minute I'm gonna hold my breath for 60
seconds and get through this impulse
yeah I'm gonna text somebody I'm gonna
call them I'm gonna get on that whatever
website he just gave you I'm gonna get
on there I'm gonna get on there I'm
gonna get on there it's I'm talking 60
Seconds
[Music]
and it makes me feel terrible I know I'm
talking bad about Kevin again but it's
like you know it makes it gives me so
much guilt to put people that I love
like with this because I did it all
myself man I don't have a terminal
illness I don't I don't have something I
can't control okay hold on hold on now
you're back to morality
and we're going to take morality off the
table you're a brave dude
we're taking morality off the table
you're sick man
yeah and you don't want to believe
you're sick you want to think that you
can just flex your way through this and
you can't
yeah there's no way there's no way
and you you're also too smart for your
own good quite honestly
I know I mean I have so many friends
that are in the same position and they
have no idea they're even addicted it's
just like they're they're norm and they
don't even here's what you're gonna have
to do here's here's every single person
who struggles with addiction I've ever
met struggles with you're gonna have to
find new people to be around yeah you're
gonna have to find new communities
you're gonna have to find new things to
do when you get stressed out or angry or
enraged or heartbroken
yeah you're gonna have to breathe
through these Seasons man and it's just
here it is it's a set of skills you play
sports before the first time somebody
told you to I don't know shoot a
basketball you had to learn how to do
that that's what you're doing man you're
learning a new set of skills
and the more you can keep an open hand
towards these new sets of skills versus
trying to close fist around it
um man the the gentler the ride and the
ride's not going to be gentle
yeah right
so it'll be worth it
cannot imagine a scenario where it's not
worth it
yeah and like you like you were saying
earlier I keep thinking you know about
how you said
you know if you're ready for the next
three months it's like I'm gonna have to
be ready at some point because it's it's
gonna kill me by itself if I don't you
know you can do it now
or you can do it in jail
or you can do it in court uh Court
mandated rehab
yeah but you're gonna do it right yeah
so here's all right here's my promise uh
I'm gonna connect you with um offline
I'm gonna connect you with Craig if
that's a somebody you want to reach out
to as a resource I also am committed to
um
I'll put you on anytime you want to come
on and let me know about your journey
okay thanks man that means a lot and if
you have
um a great month and then you fall off
the wagon all right
you're still my friend
all right I'll still pick up the tab
just come hang out and if you have two
months and you're and you're doing all
right awesome
if you have three months awesome and if
your girlfriend wants to call into the
show and say how do I love somebody
who's struggling I'd love to take that
call too okay
I'll help you every step of the way I
can hang on the line here I'm gonna send
you a copy of on your past change your
future on me just a book to say okay
here's what what's happened I've got to
own what I did period
now what
I'm gonna walk with you my brother thank
you so much for your bravery and a big
shout out again to Craig for reaching uh
for taking a last second call this
morning
um if you are struggling with addiction
can't do it by yourself
and you're worth peace be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
alright let's go to Jody in Manitoba
Canada what's up Jody
hi
how are we doing
oh I'm pretty nervous
um I am too I'm terrible at this so
we'll be nervous together it'll be fine
all right that sounds good
you sound like you totally believe me
all right so what's up
well
well sure of my marriage when fear
paralyzes me from making any kind of
decision
what decision do you have to make
or you know if I if I walk away from
this relationship you're being super
vague
okay well maybe I'll give you a little
um so I met my husband
um when I was 29. he's
seven years older than me we've been
married for about nine years now I had a
child I brought into the relationship
um which was from just kind of a short
relationship that I had but when I
discovered I was pregnant
um this father just rejected everything
so he left at that point
um so it had been about a year later and
I met my husband and I I guess you know
my my self-esteem was really low and I
probably had no business getting into a
relationship at that point but you know
here was this nice stable guy he had a
job he had a house he treated me with
respect and and I wasn't used to having
that so you know I I let him in
um we did have a bit of a rocky
relationship that was kind of on again
off again because I I you know I kept
thinking like no this isn't what I want
but you know the alternative was I I was
alone and and I just wanted somebody to
be there
um so you know we dated for about a year
and then we got engaged and you know
immediately after we got engaged I was
like oh my God this relationship is is
just moving forward and and I'm not sure
that this is the right thing
um but I just kind of you know stifled
those feelings and you know got swept up
in the excitement of planning a wedding
um so we had this huge lavish wedding
that of course we could not afford
um we decided to buy a house we went on
a honeymoon and sort of when we came
back and settled into normal everyday
life
um that's when things got really really
hard
and when you say really hard I want to
get real real clear here
really hard like he's abusive
he or or or or really hard like
you don't find him attractive
you don't like it really hard in that
you know we we started arguing a lot
it's a lot of new marriages so like what
what this seems more existential
on my part my husband travels a lot for
work so I was left
alone and I guess it wasn't what I had
been expecting out of married life I I
thought I would have this companion I
thought a relationship would be
um just wonderful and but but
I
don't
um
I'm gonna take a risk here I don't think
that the relationship is the problem
I really don't I don't think you like
Jody
because
you had a picture of a thing and it was
gonna look like this and it ended up
looking like something else yeah and
it's taken you 10 years
almost a decade
and when someone says I got left alone I
was lonely
my first question is why'd you choose
loneliness
so after your husband decides he's going
to be on the road or has to be on the
road for his job a yeah you didn't have
that conversation which I get man not a
lot I didn't have that skill set until
15 years after being married to say hey
I need this or I want this
I get that and you didn't choose to find
relationships in community with other
people which I think all married couples
need
so it sounds like you were expecting
this person I it's not like you married
a ghost is what it sounds like you
married a fantasy
and nobody there is no ghost or fantasy
that can be both super attractive and
and support you and not bother you but
also be there for you and be your
companion but not too much you see what
I'm saying it's a moving Target and
that's you anytime someone's dealing
with a moving Target
it's almost always them trying to use
external means to fill internal holes
so what is it about Jody that you don't
trust
um
I don't know I've been rejected
a lot in my life
um
relationships are really hard
for me
um me too yeah
yeah
so here's my promise to you I promise
you this
this may not be your this may not you
may not stay married to this guy long
term that's another conversation another
call if you leave him today
and meet somebody in three months you're
going to be in this exact same boat in
five to ten years
because you haven't dealt with you
yeah
is that fair
yeah that's fair
so let me ask you this one terrifying
scary question what do you want Jody
and I'm asking that in in the bound
context of you're a mom and you're a
wife
what do you want
peace
okay that comes from the inside out
yeah
what are you unpeaceful about
um
I don't know it's just
like I've completely shut down I
things that you know should should bring
me joy just don't
um
I've heard you talk on the show about
people that escape you know on Facebook
and Instagram and and just kind of
scroll their entire lives away and and
that's me to achieve like I just
I just try to escape
and it's not from some it sounds like
you're not escaping from a dragon it
sounds like you're escaping from smoke
and it's it's easier to escape a dragon
because you can see it
yeah and this feels like it's enveloping
you is that fair
yeah
you're describing to a t depression
have you gone to talk to somebody
um I actually from the time that I wrote
your show to like this call today
um I actually have one appointment with
um with a counselor good
here's what I want you to do have you
had that at that meeting yet
I've had one meeting so far how was it
um
promising okay
I think there's a really bright light at
the other end of this
but I think that you're
um I talk a lot about anxiety and OCD
and those kind of things one thing I
don't play around with is depression
just because I just look at the data
okay and it's that one's a tough one
just to think your way out of or just to
go act your way out of usually you have
to sit down with somebody and be for and
be honest often for the first time in
your life
and here's here's the goal here
Joy yes but we're looking at creating a
life worth living
and you sound like somebody who's
allowed life to happen to them for a
long long time
and you've loved parts of it and you
also thought different parts of it would
feel differently than they actually do
and there's parts of it you don't like
that don't fit your picture of what you
would what you would do Changing
Partners right now I don't know that
that fixes that it might I don't see it
yeah that's for you and your therapist
I talked to somebody recently who quit
their job as a high flute job and had
been struggling with some depression
some anxiety and quit their job and
things felt good for a few weeks and
then all of a sudden it's like oh the
depression anxiety is back and it's like
yeah
he's not an external an external
stressor would fix an internal Challenge
and it won't sometimes it'll help
sometimes changing the context will help
but
this is a long time isn't it
yeah yeah
I've been on
and I just feel like you know every time
kind of life gets harder and I go you
know to the doctor and it's just like up
my dosage up my dosage right so but but
listen when you go to the doctor to stop
feeling bad that's for most that's the
only tool they've got
and the goal right now is to not stop
feeling bad
the goal is let's build a life worth
living
and those are different things when you
tell your husband
that you're on the fence about right now
I just need you to do this and this and
this because they make those things make
me feel bad or I don't feel good I don't
feel Joy
that's different than hey would you be a
part of changing everything with me
yeah that's a totally different one is
an invitation to an adventure and the
other is a is a phone book of rules and
regulations
and that phone book moves and it pushes
and it goes and it goes
um the adventure is never ending
and so here's my promise to you go to
the counselor
and be honest about not what you want to
stop feeling as much and be honest of
course about that but also be highly
intentional intentional about asking for
skills to build a life that you want to
be a part of
and that will include really hard
conversations with your current husband
that'll include hard conversations with
your kid that'll include new boundaries
that will include you doing different
things hard things like getting up every
morning and exercise think you'll
you know whatever it will require you to
change too
it will not be easy
but you're at a stage now everybody
listening this is a stage when somebody
needs professional help
this isn't something I'm going to solve
on the radio
this isn't something you're going to
solve over a cup of coffee and this
isn't one of those things you tell
somebody you just need to you know think
more about nope
it says all the Hallmarks of somebody
who's struggling with depression
and the light on the other side of this
thing is has a brightness that you can't
only imagine Jody
to go sit with this therapist be honest
be direct
be specific about changing your life
we're rooting for you my sister we'll be
right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step when
you're facing problems or challenges in
life it's way too easy to get stuck in
that anxious spiral of Doom I've been
there but when you learn how to stop
that cycle and start taking ownership of
your life that's when you're free and
that's what therapy can help you do it
gives you the tools you need to do the
problem solving in your own life and
that's why I love better help better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours if you're ready to get the tools
that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloney to
get 10 off your first month that's
better
help.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to Jackie
in Danville what's up Jackie
oh not much just child problems
oh if you got child problems I feel bad
for you son I got 99 okay so what's up
tell me what's going on
okay so my youngest is gonna be 13 in
about a month okay
um I got a 12 year old same let's figure
this out awesome
I no longer know what to do or how to
handle situations with him okay
um
right now he is failing almost every
class okay fighting with every teacher
his school's fed up with him
um they're threatening to keep him in
the principal's office for the rest of
the year and do all of his classes
except PE in the principal's office
um he won't do chores at home and I
don't ask a lot you know keep his room
clean straighten up his bathroom into
the dishwasher I mean it's not a lot
um
I tried taking Privileges and I try
giving Privileges and bribery and
everything and I'm just I'm at a loss
oh man I'm sorry ah jeez I'm sorry
um
this sounds like a boy that doesn't feel
safe why wouldn't he feel safe
um I'm
was a single mom his father actually
passed away uh about three years ago and
he never really had anything to do with
him
um he kept it hidden from his family and
they just recently came into his life
about three or four years ago
so there's that and then you know
young dumb mom you know bounced around
so he's you know
had a
really two different stable people in
his life but
um
you say bounce around like just
different boyfriends different
boyfriends or different marriages yeah
uh only one marriage
um recently got divorced it was just a
bad situation
um what does that mean was there abuse
in the home
no I mean his my mother-in-law was
kind of a terror
um she wouldn't let him do you know
stuff on his own and would get no you
know mad like if he spilled milk corn
cereal you know dumb stuff
so
it's just a lot so I finally got out of
that situation and I moved in with um my
parents for a little while
and then you know young and dumb again
got you know went straight into another
relationship and I've been living with
him for about three years but he had
never had any children
so he doesn't know how to handle him and
I feel like I'm constantly man in the
middle
between the two of them and you know
my boyfriend's like telling this I'm
like why don't you just tell him
so I don't know what to do
and underneath all of this is a little
kid
right hiding in a teenager I keep that
in mind hiding in a teenage body
is a little kid saying what was so wrong
with me the dead left
why does God hate me so much that Daddy
died
and who the hell is this guy think he is
talking to my mom like that talking to
me like that
who is this other Grandma trying to tell
me that I'm a bad kid for spilling milk
like and all of a sudden that little 12
year old boy
his body explodes from the inside out
and so when you describe those things I
don't see a bad kid at all I see a kid
screaming somebody please tell me I'm
okay
I know and I'm I'm trying to get him to
open up and he like me or his
grandmother Jackie he has no way he's
gonna open up
no way I wouldn't
not after some third or fourth
radioactive alpha male in my house
trying to go to war with me as a 12 year
old
I'm not gonna open up in that
environment in a way
and the last time I opened up to an
elderly person she got mad at me for
spilling Corn Flakes
right
and so he sits on it he has learned I'm
gonna sit on this the only problem is he
doesn't have the strength and fortitude
or access to alcohol to do it
like most men do or he doesn't have a
graduate degree from law school to go
hide in his office for the next 40 years
and so he just explodes
he is not a bad kid
no he's not unfortunately he's too smart
for his own good
the features are constantly like he
skirts around the rules by doing this
this and this but he's not really
breaking the rules
and I constantly tell him I'm like you
know listen Jackie the words you just
said I constantly tell him I don't care
I don't care what you tell him
no words will get through to this 12
year old little boy zero words
he has learned to respond to two things
power
and connection
do you know what a dream it would be for
him to be able to do his work by himself
in a non-threatening environment in the
principal's office where adults are nice
to him
that would be the greatest gift to his
sweet little brain and his sweet little
body peace
adults who are actually kind to him
who hold him accountable and challenge
him academically but love him because he
doesn't have that
he's got a mom who is rattled From the
Inside Out probably has been for a long
time and I'm not blaming you it just
isn't is
he's gotta come on it doesn't help that
I have
dealt with depression on and off and I'm
finally getting myself healthy so I'm
you know finally getting the strength to
deal with everything good good good good
good you can he can only be as well as
you are
and I know that's a scary proposition
for you
um would it benefit to try to get him
into counseling like I keep trying to
get him into that but he's like let's go
there and I'll just stare at him so I'm
like I don't know if that's that's worth
the fight to try to
he needs a couple of men in his life
that he can actually trust and aren't
going to harp on him all the time about
it pull his pants up and fix his belt
and is that what you're wearing turn
your shirt around he needs a couple of
guys in his life they'll take him
fishing and laugh with him
oh my my
um
dad was a stepdad but he you know tries
to take him out constantly and my
boyfriend like wants to go out and do
four-wheeling and paintballing and all
that stuff with him but then he gets mad
because he's not listening to him so
yeah he I mean and it sounds like I'm
saying it's a free-for-all absolutely
not he needs to experience
accountability he needs to experience
choices but he also needs to experience
autonomy and he needs to experience more
than anything a safe environment and
he's never had that
all right
and you know this and I'm not saying
this to I'm saying this to challenge you
not to kick you while you're down okay
no I understand this is all of the
recipes for the making of a disaster
down the road
this is a brilliant
unsafe
boy about to become a brilliant unsafe
man
and that's a danger
right
and so it sounds like what he needs is a
good butt kicking nope
what he needs is to feel safe and secure
for the first time in his life
ever
this is going to sound bananas but I
would start with
you've heard me say this a million times
on the show when's the last time you
just took him out and listened to him
how things going I'm not trying to coach
you or teach you or tell you like how's
it going that's a dangerous question
because
um for the last two years my work's been
working six days a week 10 hour days so
okay I'm out of the house a lot okay
part of you getting well might be
thinking I've got to get a different job
part of you getting well might be this
like romantic relationship I'm in that
I'm in to Band-Aid over the last one
which Band-Aids over the last one which
Band-Aids over a lifetime of fill in the
blank
those aren't serving me well
and when I'm not when you don't feel
safe and by the way Jackie you don't
feel safe either I can hear it on you
you feel one one uh
one tiny like
spider's web you're hanging on by
is that true
yeah a little bit
I think part of it's just
I'm at the point where I'm like is he
going to get frustrated enough that you
know he's gonna want to kick us out
of the home
why are you trying to please him
why
because he's the first person that's
actually made me feel like I have a life
and I'm worth living then he shouldn't
be making you feel like you got to
perform for him or he or you're you're
off the stage
and he might not be saying those words
but that might be what you're projecting
on to him and that's not fair if you're
doing that to him
kind of keeps bottle stuff balled up
bottled up and you know has a hard time
explaining I know but you know women and
children are
Exquisite at absorbing that sort of
tension you know why because they have
to to keep alive
and so when he's all bottled up you feel
it and you can nuzzle up to him and be
romantic and make the meal that you can
do all those things bring home the
paycheck that he wants you can do that
but your body knows we're not safe
all right you know especially knows that
the finest tuned radar in your home is
that sweet little 13 year old boy
not one thing you've described to me is
out of character for that little boy
I'm so heartbroken for him I can hardly
even stand it because I gotta I got a
boy just like him
the difference is announce again I'm not
perfect parent by a long shot
my kid can be goofy he can be a 12 year
old he can be a 13 year old he can do
all all the middle school boy things
but that boy knows he's safe and that
boy knows he is loved
all right
and that's where we're going to start
with him
very like quick out of the gate if you
said give me three things to do right
now
I would say you have to figure out a
work schedule where you go to
you leave in the morning early or you go
in the evening and you take him on a
date once a week
without fail twice a week if you can
no boyfriend no whatever you all to go
together
I can do that I get home at 4 30 in the
afternoon so awesome and once a week he
gets to pick the restaurant once a week
you get to pick it
and it might mean you can't afford it
and you're gonna have to forego
something cool foreign
well I mean it's pretty I've taken my
son there
um sometimes he picks that place just to
torture me but that is what it is and
then I get Dorito tacos and everything's
better for about eight minutes well I'm
on a carnivore diet so I'll probably
have to fast while he's eating it no but
don't no no no don't do that eat
forget the con what's like why do the
car why now why now
because it's helping my migraines and my
depression and all that good stuff all
right or whatever there's a good reason
okay
Taco Bell will not help those three
things
um right I'll just eat the beef he gets
to pick
and here's what we're gonna do
we are not going to lecture him whenever
you feel yourself reaching up to give
him advice you're gonna stop
you're gonna listen
you're going to ask him questions like
what scares you
what are you missing I'm gonna send you
all the questions for humans cards you
can use with him okay
you can take them and this is going to
be your date it's gonna be your game and
then if he has another game he wants to
play cool if he wants to get a puzzle
and just not talk cool
the second thing we're gonna do every
single morning and every single evening
before bed you are gonna hug him to your
chest
for 30 seconds and he doesn't get a vote
but he kind of does
okay and you're not gonna say mama needs
a hug because he already feels like he
has to take care of you and he can't
carry that
all right you're going to say mom really
wants to hug her the most important man
in her life
will you give Mom the opportunity to hug
the man that she loves more than any
other man on the planet
that's what we're gonna say every single
day
and then he's gonna go
and you'll say
I want to hug the most important man of
the planet
the third thing is you have to be on the
lookout for
male influences in his life then aren't
just going to take a paintball and show
him how to drink beer and how to whip
ass and be a man not that
who are going to see him and love him
and provide a good model for what this
what being a man looks like and that's
doing hard stuff
and that's being honest and that's being
open and that's being vulnerable and
that's feeling things and going and
doing hard crap anyway
and if that's not your boyfriend get out
get out
foreign
would it be beneficial to have my father
try to take him out once a week too if
you think that's a safe good person
he's amazing that would be incredible
and now this little boy is going to
start getting the thing he needs more
than anything else which is adults who
love him who not don't tell him who show
him through their most precious resource
their time
he's gonna get something he desperately
needs which is to be fully seen and have
be at be rest assured I still love you
awesome okay and did you by the way you
were playing a 10-year game here what
we're doing right now we are hoping that
that 25 year old kid
who's now 25 year old man
with all of the rights and privileges of
grown men
in our society we're hoping that guy
looks back and thinks man my mom really
had a rough go of it the first decade of
my life and that that brave incredible
woman turns it around
man I was really blessed to have my
grandpa in my life
that guy walked alongside me and he was
met with me every week forever drove me
crazy and I'm missing like crazy
okay well luckily we're a pretty young
family so he'll have him for a while
cool but but you're but all that to say
is this isn't going to get better in
four months
okay the last thing I'll tell you is
this is number four and then I'll let
you go
I would come up with some sort of set of
family values that he gets to speak into
foreign and that might be on your third
or fourth or fifth or sixth
date that you'll have in a row
you could tell them hey I've been
wondering who I'm gonna be who I want to
be who you want to be and not just what
job we're going to do but who are we
going to be
would you make a list with me let's do a
project together
and this will be a project that says
we're going to talk to people with
respect and dignity we we get our work
done on time we show up on time that's
just who we are where people who treat
other people right and we treat them
right by if they give us an assignment
we just get it done
and that way when he chooses to not do
his homework you've got something back
to say Hey you chose this consequence
too because you know who we are we all
agreed on it
and he gets to hold you accountable mom
when you yell and scream or kick or
throw something he gets to say ah
that's not Who We Are we said we were
going to be this
and then you have to pay him 20 bucks
that's the fine
film chair is it fair but here's what
we're doing the the nerd word is
autonomy
we're giving him some tiny feeling that
he has some bit of control in his life
and up to this point he's had none
no control
he has been at the whim of adults who
are doing acting like children running
around doing Child Things in adult
bodies
and he's terrified and now he's got man
now that sweet little boy has a chance
to just do his homework in peace at the
principal's office and principles can be
tough but man they love
smart good kids
[Music]
and those school secretaries in the
principal's office and those School
administrators
[Music]
they would be nice to
them your kids everybody when your kids
are
acting out
let your first question not be what's
wrong with my kid
let your first question be why doesn't
my kid feel safe
start there
solve for safety
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show one
of the greatest
metal Rock anthems of all time ever
this one's near and dear to my heart me
and Mike and Tom and others used to jam
this when we were kids
by the great Twisted Sister in the song
is We're Not Gonna Take It
I can't believe I haven't thought
of
Legend
we've got the right to choose yeah there
ain't no way we'll lose it this is our
life this is our song We'll Fight the
powers that be just don't pick our
destiny because you don't know us you
don't belong
We're Not Gonna Take It no We're Not
Gonna Take It We're not gonna take it
anymore oh you're so condescending your
gall is never ending you don't want
nothing we don't want nothing not a
thing from you your life is Triton jaded
boring and confiscated if that's your
best your best won't do it's so great
we're right yeah we're free yeah we'll
fight you'll see We're not gonna take it
anymore
I was gonna say We're Not Gonna Take It
on this show either but I take it every
single show so we'll see you soon
[Music]